Will and Jada get very real about how
their marriage fell apart and here's the
thing nobody knew about me you know no
did you know we've known him for a long
time and there's a lot we never knew
there was always just so much god that's
God but now will is getting the final
word let's clear some rumors just to
have it on record just a historical
rumors we've never been Scientologists
we've never been swingers never been me
never been swinging understood that's a
specific lifestyle doesn't really
specific slide we never been swingers
Will and Jada shot down a few rumors
today on Jada's read Table Talk series
but some of their comments raised
questions like do they have an open
marriage
that's all Wolfram the Gator said let me
tell you something if you marry me know
this we're gonna be together we're gonna
be under the same roof you might be on
one end of that joke about somebody else
we're gonna be yeah in this joker
together Will and Jada who have been
married for 20 years
revealed today that the lowest point in
their marriage was Jada's 40th birthday
that's when I had a midlife crisis will
held an over-the-top birthday weekend
that included a short film he made about
Jada and a performance by mary j blige
she told me that the party was the most
ridiculous display of my ego Oh crushed
right and to this day I know I was
crushed cuz it was true from that rock
bottom the couple turned their
relationship around we essentially had
to destroy our marriage we broke up
within our marriage and got back
together again we don't even call
ourselves married yeah you know it's a
life partnership I always knew
I'm not marriage material what I am is
right a die chick what you are is the
best friend that I've ever had
[Music]